all right Christian
yes Christian uh where are you from
originally
so I'm from Birmingham Alabama I've uh
pretty much been born and raised in
Birmingham Alabama uh did a short stint
in Tuscaloosa for college but uh Alabama
born and raised so if you can't tell
from my accent now you know
and uh
tell me about your uh just a brief
summary of your uh your childhood grown
up yeah
um childhood was just pretty much
um
virtually Picture Perfect
um parents were always there you know
Mom the school teacher dad was in the
military reserves and also worked at
Alabama Power
um so you know they uh they kept us
happy had an older sister of course and
yeah I just I really had just a
picture-perfect childhood that's great
um you know it's
it's uh I can tell it's it's led to a
lot of great things down the life as
well so and what you went to went to
high school and college yes uh so um I
went to Hoover High School um so anybody
out there familiar with uh there's an
MTV show called uh two a days um that's
where I went to high school don't know I
even brought that up but I did but uh
graduated from Hoover uh then went to
the great uh University of Alabama uh so
I'll give a roll tide for everybody out
there but uh what have you done for work
um so a slew of things
um a slew of things uh so when I got out
of college I was starting in sports
event management
um so we would do a lot of events
setting up for Alabama football games we
also uh focused uh on a track that was
local to Birmingham they have an indie
race out there about
one yes once a year
um so we would set up for that and some
other events out there not absolutely I
loved it it was really the dream job for
out of college but of course once
everything happened I needed to make a
little bit of a career shift so went
into banking
um that was an experience retail banking
um very fun uh then I went into
corporate sales account management uh
with background screening and drug
testing and now I am currently a
technically a design consultant for
company rebath basically going in
helping folks redesign bathroom
and try and sell it excellent and uh
you had an accident yes tell me about
that yeah so uh February 27th uh 2016.
um it was a Saturday a very interesting
day uh we had a meeting with my father
earlier that day after the meeting we
went and had lunch and then he actually
went and bought a new to him car he was
looking for a new car so went out and
test rode that with him and he ended up
making the purchase
um so I was driving his old car back
um back home and um
for whatever reason we've never got of a
really a definitive answer if you will
but uh there was a fire that started in
the passenger floorboard
um I was driving down I-65 South anybody
in the Birmingham area will know where
that is
and I had a fire that started in the
passenger floorboard so
here I am you know going 70 miles down
the interstate and I look over and kind
of look back up the road and I'd do the
Double Take I'm like wait what is this
what is going on here and um
it was really interesting about that
same time the interstate starts to curve
into a left curve and when they looked
at my tire tracks I continued going
straight instead of going into the left
curve so I ended up running off the road
now
it was really interesting because when
the car came to a stop
I knew it was on fire I you know total
Instinct you know fight or flight kicked
right in I knew hey I've got to get out
of this car immediately now what I
didn't realize was that when I ran off
the road I went into Irvine and kind of
flipped the car on its side so
when I try to get out of the car I
pulled the door handle tried to push
open the driver's side door
nothing buds I figured maybe the lock
was still on something happened fidgeted
with the lock
tried again nothing happened now
at this point
um a 24 year old young male nothing
bad has happened to me up to this point
in life really I was in the gym every
day working out so
I thought well surely I can break out
this driver side window so I had a
little jacket on and started punching it
elbowing it and it just it didn't budge
for whatever reason I just could not
break this window and at that point I
had that you know
there's all these infomercials for these
things that cut your seat belt and break
out the glass and like I was sitting
there I was like dang man I wish I had
one of those right now I wish I wish I
didn't pass those infomercials up but uh
I did and of course I think the rear
airbags had gone off so there was no
climbing back through the back if you
will and of course the fire was just
being fueled in the passenger side so
I'm kind of sitting like this the fire
was large it was a big fire
yes
um and the other theory that we had
about the fire was when the car came
to an angle that the fuel line was
actually siphoning gas from the fuel
tank up to the fire
so it just continued to grow and grow
however I didn't
really realize the extent of the fire my
adrenaline was going 110 miles an hour I
didn't feel a thing I had the most
intense tunnel vision I've ever had in
my life
um but you know once I I couldn't get
that door open or break the window I
really just thought you know I had that
moment where I just said this is how I
get you know this is this is the way I
go and
you know it's a little cliche because
you hear people say this and talk about
things that happen in near-death
experiences
and I had all these memories that kind
of Flash before my eyes you know all
these great memories I had you know with
my dad with my mom with my sister
and it was It was kind of interesting
because it
was a flash of just almost picture-like
um and then I had this just Moment of
clarity where I was like you know I
can't I can't go like this this is gonna
be it's gonna be way too painful to die
like this you know you always hear burn
alive that's got to be extremely painful
so
I slid down in the driver's side seat
um and I began to kick the windshield
now at this point I was
I probably had about pinpoint Vision
just because the tunnel vision was so
intense about the fourth kick of the
windshield however I got it to crack
it's pretty amazing
um that I actually got to crack and then
on the fifth kick I actually had a hole
in the windshield now
of course this all felt like 60 Minutes
had passed by but it was probably more
like five minutes maximum
um but by the time I got that hole in
the windshield uh two bystanders uh
edrick Williams and John de blue uh two
friends of mine now to this day uh ran
down and they grabbed a big old stick
and they were like Hey we're going to
get you out of here you just got to help
us push and to me you know I felt no
pain I had no idea what was going on so
I was like yeah no problem let's get out
of here here it's like no problem
um so they got a big old stick in that
hole and pulled the rest of the
windshield out
and when they did that
you know I stuck my arms out and they're
like all right push off the console and
they grabbed me by my wrist and I of
course pushed off the console and they
got me out of the car now
there's a lady at the top of the hill
right she's screaming the car is going
to explode you see all the Hollywood
movies typically cars don't explode I'll
go ahead and say that
um however at that time I didn't really
know so I was very concerned about the
car exploding but they got me out and
they carried me for probably a couple of
feet before they set me down
uh and when they set me down I was like
guys what you know what are we doing
here we got to get out of here this is
this is serious but what I didn't
realize was that I was completely
engulfed in flames at that point
um so when they actually had grabbed my
wrist everything just melted away
so when they set me down it was because
they were getting burned on their hands
and because there was just nothing to
grab onto
now luckily as I mentioned earlier I was
in a meeting with my dad earlier that
day and I had some leather shoes on a
leather belt
um so they grabbed me by my leather belt
and by my leather shoes and They Carried
me to the top of the hill now
again I'm Still Still In This pinpoint
Vision I don't have real full vision yet
a full peripheral at that point uh but
they get me to the top of the hill of
course I'm being Carriage you know face
down
and I really opened my eyes and I look
at my legs to try and just get a gauge
of how bad things really are
and I looked at my legs and I had some
some denim type pants on that day
but the pants and my skin it was
just dripping away like candle wax
um
you know the thing I thought in that
moment was wow this is
this is like a Hollywood movie like
because this is what you see in you know
Batman and all this stuff and you see
all these major Burns and you know I was
looking at it on my own body so that was
a little bit of a wake-up call but they
set me down right after
um it's very interesting it was it's
really like a short a wave of pain that
really started the very top of my head
and then just went through my body and
that was the last thing I remembered
um so I went in the shock at that point
now this is again on I-65 a major
Interstate uh going through Birmingham
so we've got traffic stop we've got
ambulances fire trucks everywhere
um and they got me into the ambulance of
course and took me to uh the only level
one trauma Hospital in the uh County of
Jefferson or really in the state of
Alabama I think
um and what's interesting was the whole
time I was telling the EMT my dad's name
his cell phone number you know who to
contact all these things
zero recollection of that
so they got me to this hospital and
you know the prognosis was was not great
um at that time they were looking they
were thinking that I had a 90 95 Burns
to or third degree burns to 90 to 95 of
my body at that point and the way they
do the consultations for a burn that
large as they pull the family in that
evening
say you're 90 burned they're gonna say
well
you got about a five to ten percent
chance to live
um so my brother and my now
brother-in-law
um who was engaged to my sister at the
time he was working in government so he
had the wherewithal to record the
conversation
so I got to listen to the family consult
the that Saturday night and the doctor
said you know got a five to ten percent
chance to make it through uh that night
he said if I did make it through the
night I would never walk out of the
hospital and I I would likely be on
dialysis for the rest of my life I can
go for a jog today and never been on
dialysis so and we'll talk about how we
got there too as well
um so obviously you know as a parent
that's not encouraging to hear
um you know as a family member that's
just not what you want to hear
um so you know I think the Saturday
night all my friends kind of started to
flood UAB I think they might have
overwhelmed the hospital a little bit
um
but uh you know Sunday came and I was
still fine
um UAB I'll say the hospital name now
they weren't planning on doing surgery
until Wednesday if you know anything
about burn care you know skin the skin
is your largest organ on your body
so once you lose really I always say
over 40 to 50 percent you really need to
get into a specialized Burn Center
and you need to get covered with either
cadaver skin or something to protect you
because I think it makes up about 80
percent of your body and that's just
basically a petri dish if you will for
infections and fungal infections and
just viruses so it's really important to
start a debridement process very quickly
or as soon as possible and like I said
you know we weren't starting this
process until really four days after so
really crazy thing my mother calls them
God Winks just a couple of interventions
that happened along
um along my journey that kind of put me
to where I am today
on Sunday
my sister's now father-in-law David
Helton came up to my dad and pulled him
aside and said you know I know this um
this greater burn attorney in the state
of Georgia and he knows this Doctor
Who's supposedly world renowned and
burns and I got a cell phone number you
want to give him a call
and you know parents sitting there
looking at five to ten percent chances
is like yeah we'll try anything
um so my dad calls this world-renowned
burn doctor on Sunday night on his cell
phone he picks up
my dad tells him everything that's going
on he says have his doctor call me
Monday when she comes in for rounds
so Monday morning she comes in my dad
says hey I've got this doctor I want I
kind of want you to talk to so they talk
go back and forth she fills them in on
my case uh what's you know going on with
everything
and they agreed to admit me
and so the doctor gets off the phone and
comes to my dad and says you know they
agree to Mitch you or admit your son you
know what do you want to do
and my dad says well if this was your
son what would you do
and she said I'd transport them
um so about an hour and a half after
that transpired
um the med jet team came in got me all
wrapped up
um stabilized and probably I would say
another 30 minutes after that I was on a
med jet over to Augusta Georgia to JMS
Burn Center in Doctors Hospital JMS has
now changed to brca I like to make that
designation but
um it took about 45 minutes to get to
Augusta in about another 20 minutes
after that I was in the operating room
to start my first surgery
now
my sister's husband yeah his family's
friend had friends who
had a plane that came and picked up my
family and took them over to Augusta so
they were about 45 minutes behind me and
when my dad got off the plane he was
given surgical consent to the doctor
that we haven't even really met yet to
begin surgery
um so that that Monday night uh started
or had my first it was a seven and a
half hour surgery
a debridement of I think it was the
backside they started first
and everything went well everything went
great uh so you know after the surgery
how he pulls my dad's side says you know
he did great you know what we're going
to do is
in the morning we're going to flip them
over and do the other side
so next morning
went back into surgery did another eight
hour surgery uh for full debridement and
you know the rest that kind of really
just started my journey at what is now
brca or Doctors Hospital in Augusta
Georgia
so
I I consider it a medically induced coma
they use a cocktail of drugs of course
to create Amnesia because those first
stages of burn care
you don't want to remember those
um it is
burn care is it it takes a special
person with a special heart
um
that has a higher calling I'll just I
can just leave it at that it's
um it's pretty remarkable
so I was in a medically induced coma for
about a month and a half
kind of two I started coming out but I
was still in and out for about two
months
um it's really funny the first thing I
really really remember outside of the in
Crazy almost
psychedelic dreams that I was having or
hallucinate hallucinations I'm not sure
exactly what it was
um was one of my physician assistants
coming up to to me and and telling me
that hey
um this was the first first thing I
heard it was so strange to me she was
like don't worry you're still going to
be able to have kids you're you're fine
you're fine and maybe they had told me
stuff before this and that was just this
was the first thing that really
connected
um but
to me when they when you've got a large
burn they use
I'll try not to get into too many
details but they use a thing called a
BMS and what that stands for is a bowel
management system
and what it is is basically two they put
up the rectum that way you can
pass without getting it in to the burns
and causing infection
so I woke up with one of those
um and because of the wild dreams I was
having I thought I had sat on a Coke can
and so my physician assistant she's
sitting here telling me Oh you're going
to be able to have kids again one day
and I'm sitting here telling her trying
and telling her that
I sat on a Coke can I need you to get
this out of me because it's
uncomfortable and I can't like rest with
this of course we had to live with that
for a few more weeks but that was really
my first interaction now of course I
also had a tracheotomy
which is basically where they make a
hole in your neck hook you up to a
ventilator and use the ventilator to
assist with breathing that way you can
kind of get your lungs back under you
because I did have I had a little bit of
smoke bit smoke damage but not too much
of course they can also go in and
basically scrub that out of your lungs
now which is pretty remarkable
um
but really the the main process for
everything kind of started really before
I woke up and then once I woke up was
was when the the work began
um
the first major major surgery I had was
for a process called ceas it's culture
and epithet autograph I'm butchering
that name but what it is when you have a
large burn
let me back up when you have a smaller
burn you know if you've got a third 30
burn you've got a lot of surface area to
take skin grafts from now when you get
into those higher numbers you know
there's not so much good skin to take
grafts from and cover the rest of the
body
so what they actually do this is pretty
much The Cutting Edge of burn care right
now of course it's changing every day
but they took a postage sized piece of
skin I've got a good piece of skin here
on my arm
and they send it off to a lab in Boston
and what this lab does is take that
piece of skin puts in an incubator and
they grow sheets and sheets and sheets
of skin now if you know anything about
skin there's one there's two layers
there's the epidermis and the dermis now
when they grow it I think it's only the
epidermis layer the outer layer
but that is what they use for what I
call the cea surgery now the cea surgery
is a three-step process
um
and it is a mental test
um it was probably one of the most
challenging things I had to do so uh the
first step is they take you back for a
debridement
um so the first thing they do when you
get you in there they take you back
again to make sure that the surface
where they're putting the cas is
completely clean and you know you're not
worried about infection or anything like
that
um and they do that step they'll get a
notification from the lab that they're
sending in the skin about a day or two
before it's actually getting there so
they'll go ahead schedule that surgery
wait for the skin to arrive and then
when the skin does arrive that's when
you've got the major surgery
so the way the cea process works and
it's all dependent on how much you're
trying to cover
but the cea pieces they come in one by
one squares now the first one I had was
on my legs and that's a lot of surface
area to cover so what they do is
actually they run it through a machine
and it stretches it out so it takes that
one by one and maybe turns it into like
a four by four or three by three that
way you can actually cover more skin or
more surface
but it also makes a thinner skin as well
so the way they do that you go back into
that second Pro or second step surgery
um and these pieces of skin have little
backing a little plastic backing on them
and they just staple them onto the body
one by one
now once that procedure is over
you've got to be completely still for
seven to ten days you don't want to move
at all because you don't want the thin
skin to Shear you want that skin to
actually take hold into the body so
you've got virtually you remain
motionless for about seven to ten days
now of course my first one that was
difficult because I was not really in a
state of consciousness to be able to
accept and say hey
yeah I need to be still so it was really
interesting the doctor came in and was
like we're gonna have to give you a
paralytic if you don't
be still because I was flashing
thrashing around throwing my legs
everywhere
and for anyone that doesn't know what a
paralytic is basically
it is an IV injection and when you have
a paralytic really the only thing that
you can move are your eyeballs
um so that makes a person completely
immobile except for their eyeballs and
I was completely unconscious but when he
said that I quit thrashing around I quit
worrying about I uh some for whatever
reason I behaved I had my arms and my
legs strapped to the bed but I calmed
down after I heard all that
um but that was really the the main step
and then of course after that seven to
ten day period they take you back for
another procedure and they removed that
actual plastic back and from the skin so
it's really a three-step process
um are you still going through surgeries
now are you
um I haven't really had any surgeries
lately
um you know I've gotten to the point
where it's just really easier
and most most circumstances easier to
adapt than try to change things learn
something new and then adapt that way
too I've pretty much got everything
figured out I can work out with
dumbbells and do all that great stuff
are there limitations in life now
um a little bit here and there of course
you know my hand
um is probably I guess one of the
biggest limitations you know you lose
mobility in the hand
but what I will say about the hand is
that this was initially intended to be
completely removed when I was at the
first hospital however when I got to JMS
now brca
the doctor said Dr Fred Mullins
may he rest in peace
um said we're just going to wrap this
hand we're going to leave it alone we're
going to let it heal and at the end
we're going to work on it and did just
that and
it was a very painful healing process at
the end because you
become very sensitive when you're not
touching your hands and you've got to
burn on there everything becomes
extremely sensitive so I would have to
just wrap my hand in just a standard
wrap and it would take an hour and a
half just because of the pain it was
just it was kind of unreal of course I
had some great physical therapists Brett
and Logan they were fantastic they just
they wanted to work with me and I wanted
to work with them and that kind of made
all the difference in my recovery being
able to get Mobility back and
you know when I was finally conscious of
everything it was really about three
months after everything had happened
that I learned the extent of everything
I was going back for another caa's cea
surgery
um and the anesthesiologist who I had
not had before once you're in the
hospital for some time you tend to get
and meet the people that are caring for
you very well I had not had him before
and I told him I was like man I'm
extremely nervous about the surgery
and he was like what are you what are
you talking about I was like I'm just
really nervous to have surgery
and he was like
you've had 20 surgeries already what do
you what do you mean and I was like he's
willing me to the or and I'll look at
him like
20 searches what happened
he was like no you you had 80 third
degree burns
and that's when it clicked I was like oh
so this was
a lot bigger than I thought because you
were kind of out of it for most of it
right yeah and when I woke up I didn't
have any broken bones no brain trauma I
have no trauma at all other than the
burns so I woke up a 24 year old just
ready to go home you know
um and really I guess when I woke up was
around the master some so sometime
around April my birthday is April 24th
um so my goal was to get out by April
24th you know make the uh make the moves
I needed to do and get out by April 24th
and um
you know I'm up Pas and nurses were like
okay we'll we'll shoot for that
um but of course I didn't end up leaving
until uh August 1st so I was in there
for about five months in a day so how
how have you handled this emotionally
when you were finally yeah um
you know it's obviously it's it's a
challenging thing to accept at first
um
you know you you
go through 24 years of looking at the
same thing in the mirror every day and
then everything changes your Mobility
changes
um you've you know you're completely
looking at yourself and you're just like
I don't even recognize myself
um so that you know that that does pose
a challenge
um but the way I tried to approach it I
try to be a little bit more Analytical
in things in the way I approach things
um
I had a of course my family virtually
moved over to Augusta so my parents they
were there every I had four visiting
sessions a day totaling two hours so
they could visit me four times a day
didn't miss a single one
um I had just now pouring of support I
think like I was getting cut postcards
from like 11 different countries and had
people make me posters and collages and
they were direct decorated in the
hospital room so it wasn't like the
sterile environment I had all these
things from friends and family
so that really kind of helped boost my
mood but I also had a just
an unbelievable care team
um I really can't say I can't say enough
about my care team
um but there's one person in particular
of course my physical therapists were
really in the trenches with me every day
and and doing the hard work which was
you know making a person move that
doesn't want to move
um but you know Kim litcom was one of
she kind of bounced around as a nurse
but I don't know what it was I guess it
was she had boys that were similar in my
age so she kind of took this motherly
role towards me if you will
um
and you know she would come in there and
we'd chat and she was just everybody
knew you know they've been in Burn care
for so long they know how to direct the
emotional part of things
so you know for me it became you know it
wasn't a why why me why me Mark
it became a why me you know why did this
happen to me what's what's my purpose
now
was your general view of it you that you
were very unlucky or very lucky
um the general view was that I was lucky
um because you know like you could have
taken either just you know either side
right right and you know of course I
think
that's very common in the hospital
um
we had always my dad would always joke
was with our physical therapist that
they would say it was so easy to work
with me like it was they enjoyed working
with me because I would work with them
and you know my dad always said you know
a lot of times especially you know older
folks they run into situations they get
in the hospital and they just want
somebody to rub their feet and help them
go to the bathroom
um and I I get it I get it 100 I'm 100
empathetic to that because
you know like we see on your channel not
everybody has this picture perfect
upbringing that is gonna help them
through these trials that you know life
throws at us
um but for me it was uh this this I
always think this and it sounds so
cliche or corny if you will but
I almost had this line mentality
um you know I wanted I wanted to get out
of that hospital I wanted to go home I
just want to go home that's all I want
to do I just want to go home and I knew
the only way I was going to get to go
home is if I worked
so
I just had to do the line mentality when
the physical therapist came didn't
matter how I was feeling
um they were going to come and nag you
until they got you up and I thank them
for that now
and the reason I say this is because for
the next young adult that's sitting in
the bed in the ICU thinking hey my
life's over this is going to change
everything for the rest of my life you
know life's not really going to go on
how I wanted it to
well
um just to let you know it if you listen
to what the doctors say you do the work
you put the work in
um you can get back to living a
productive and happy life
so and of course you know I say that
this all happened in 2016 so we're we've
got some time to look back on it and of
course there was I won't lie there's
days where I didn't want to get out of
the bed or the physical therapist had
come in
and they're like all right well we'll
come back and check on you an hour and I
would be watching that clock so closely
um but when they came
it was it was time to work but I had a
lot of work to do of course when you're
if you think about it you know think
about taking a
multi-hour plane line plane ride if you
don't get up from your seat you're
feeling kind of like I feel stiff I can
end up moving around or stretch or
something
now try sitting there in Mobile for
about two months
you lose everything so
uh it was kind of remarkable this was
something that caught me completely off
guard that I didn't expect and of course
what did I tell everybody is Burns or
something you don't have to know about
until you have to know about them
but I needed assistance just to roll
over on my side
I couldn't sit up I couldn't roll over I
had to have two people or one person on
each side to assist me with walking had
to relearn how to eat
um I had to relearn how to do everything
and that was a challenge because like I
said you know I was I went from 24 year
old spring chicken to
I can't even get out of bed on my own
um did you have moments where you were
you know down and depressed about it ah
it's a you know there's there are
certainly times where I felt discouraged
because when you're
in there time slows down because you're
just pretty much trapped in these walls
you're seeing the same people you get
visits from your family but other than
that it's
really you in this isolated room until
your nurse comes in or the doctor comes
in but
it leaves you there a lot of uh leaves
you with a lot of time to think about
things and that's you know one of the
other things I wanted to mention is
you know four
that time in my life I thought
you know everything like I said it was
you know just about Picture Perfect up
to that point
um and really though I think what a lot
of young adults don't get to do in this
age of social media and go go go go
is no one stops and
takes account of how they're doing no
one checks in on themselves no one says
well do I need to course correct here or
do I need to keep going
how I'm going and I think that really
gave me the time to stop and really
reflect I won't say
um
I I wasn't
I wasn't like a bad guy per se but I was
very self-absorbed
um you know I kind of had really left
relationships on the table with other
women in college you know just
I was just so self-absorbed and
when you're in the hospital you know
especially in the ICU for four and a
half months there's action going on all
the time there's noises it's hard to
sleep so I had a lot of time to take
notes on myself and really course
correct and I mentioned this before we
started and and I know you've said this
in several interviews but you know for
you the channel is a crash course in
empathy
um and for me this
trial if you will was really a crash
course in empathy as well because once I
was in the ICU and spending time there
there was other patients that I was
hearing about and connecting with their
families you know when you've got one
family sitting in a waiting room for
four hours and your family's sitting at
the right day after day
eventually Southern Hospitality is going
to kick in and somebody's gonna he's
gonna say hey how you doing you know
don't need to check on your loved one or
do anything so we had a system like that
um that we had that been the biggest
change that you've seen is is just your
gratitude yeah absolutely
um
and I think that's why I'm drawn to the
channel so much is because it gives me a
chance to see these people that
you know all walks of life of course but
you know a lot of folks that we may say
hey you know these people are different
from me so I don't really want to you
know they can do their thing or whatever
but stay over here
but now I look at it at a or through
lens rather that
you know
everybody in life goes through something
there's no there's no escaping life
without a trial without a tribulation
um and what always what I learned when I
went in to do peer support training for
burns survivors
is that
doesn't matter how big the burn is it's
going to likely be the most attractive
experience of their lives
so if you're thinking about it you know
everyone this was what would always
happen to me in the hospital everybody
would say oh 80 that's so terrible you
know I was only burned you know 40 or 30
percent now I'm like but that was that's
obviously the worst thing that's ever
happened to you right that's the most
painful thing you've ever been through
you know and they're like well yeah
it really was I was like
so your burn is right here next to mine
because it doesn't matter what you've
been through the worst thing that you've
ever been through is the worst thing
you've ever been through
so there's no there's really no
comparison as far as Burns or really
anything else in life
um
it just it is what it is the worst thing
you've been through is the worst thing
that you've been through and really up
until that point you don't know anything
else it's kind of if you think like a
baby you know a baby laughs or they cry
and that's just because they don't know
how to express any other emotions and
it's kind of this I kind of liken it to
the same thing that you know you just
don't know until you know what the next
worst thing is
um so you know it was very interesting
the mental part you know again I had
psychiatrists counselors I mean they
would come to my room we would talk
about things they would assist me with
anything that I needed help with but
you know I had such a strong support
system so many people riding me let I
mean I would I would get 14 15 letters a
day I mean it was just I never got that
much mail in my life it was crazy
um but I had so much support
um and I think
my family my specifically my mom and dad
being able to move over there and then
of course my sister coming in just about
whenever and now
my brother-in-law's brother and sister
they were also living in Augusta so they
would come and check on me so
I I saw I saw
firsthand what that does for patient
care there's another patient I won't get
into specifics I don't want to get
anybody into trouble
um but there was another patient there a
little bit younger than me had been
there for over a year
um and what I was told was you know it
had some troubles leading up to it
and essentially had to try to
self-immolate with gasoline
um so he was in the burn center and
apparently his mom showed up one day and
she walked in the room and said
something to the effect of you really
effed up now
and then turned around and walked out
the staff never saw her again
and for whatever reason you know
he just surgeries wouldn't take just
couldn't heal
just no matter whatever they threw at
him that just didn't work and I'm not
saying that you know family and support
systems are
you know 80 90 100 percent of the care
but
um you know it really it really makes a
difference and of course
now the other thing also is nutrition is
is a big thing for burns
um which is difficult because well I had
a feeding tube of course but
it was feeding tube whatever my parents
could bring me the hospital meals they
wanted me to eat everything I was
burning
it's burning about 4 000 calories a day
just just laying there just just not
even doing anything because my body was
healing so it needed the energy and
you know I thought I'll be honest at the
beginning I gave some push back to it
because
when you don't eat anything for two
months your stomach shrink so you know
they're like eat whatever you want which
sounds like a dream to most people but
your stomach's really shrunk
um and you're like on these all these
medications and everything that you just
you just kind of feel out of it and not
ready to eat but nutrition was another
big piece of it and of course
um towards the end there I was taken
down like
I want to say like 2000 2500 calories
just in nutrition shakes a day so but uh
you know the whole the whole experience
was was really interesting and
you know overall
once I started to get better really
towards month three
um I actually started healing a lot
faster than they anticipate
um so I was going back in for
debridements on my right arm
almost every other day because when
when you have a large burn the skin
normally heals slowly so it kind of
comes back together real smoothly but if
I don't want to give myself too much
credit but if you're following nutrition
and healing quickly then the skin will
go quickly and then it will start to
raise and you get all these bumps so
they would take me back to to breathe
those bumps every other day or so
but
um that just showed that the sign of you
know how well I was I was healing
um
and about that time uh I would say you
know a parent started feeling a little
comfortable you know going back home and
taking care of things over there and I
felt more comfortable because all the
nursing excuse me all the nursing staff
knew me
um you know as I basically felt like a
celebrity in the hospital as well
because when you're there so long with a
large burn you know everybody learns
about you because it's an interesting
story say the least
um so you know it it was a it was a
really interesting transitioning from
the burn ICU up into
Inpatient Rehab for Mobility
um now of course in the ICU I was
virtually on well not virtually I was on
24 7 Around the Clock pain medication
and
anti-fungals antivirals all this kind of
stuff and when I went to Inpatient Rehab
it was
not all that
um you know I didn't have all these
leads and feeding tubes and IVs and
everything so it it gave me a chance to
be like wow I didn't realize how poorly
I was resting in the the ICU until I got
up here to where it was quiet they
turned the lights out at night and
everything
but
even though I spent really two weeks and
Inpatient Rehab that was that was just
like a whole other fold of of an empathy
lesson for me because it wasn't just
burn survivors
um sure there were a couple burn
survivors up there and
uh there's actually a Spanish speaking
family up there that I kind of got to
know because my dad spoke Spanish and
the family was having trouble
communicating with the staff so my dad
would go help and translate and of
course we got to know him from that
again another crazy story but I saw the
way you know his recovery went and just
I mean it kind of made me self-reflect
and say wow you know
this is I got the best of the best
um and you know I didn't mention this
earlier but
when my dad initially called the doctor
while I was still in Birmingham
the doctor said look we're gonna we're
gonna throw everything that we got at
him
just know that right up front
and they did and fortunately it doesn't
always work out like this but
fortunately for me
um you know a lot of it took and a lot
of it works
um so you think your positive attitude
somehow help with your recovery
absolutely
um and I I kind of sounded like well
yeah yeah
um yeah it definitely plays into it
um because how was your how was your
life today
life today is great life's great today
is is great you know
um I get to go out in my job meet people
help them that's really my number one
thing is
trying to help people and just kind of
learn about people I'm
I've got a girlfriend now and she
mentioned the other day she's like
sometimes you're kind of like a you kind
of come off as a know-it-all
and I was like
I know I come off as a know-it-all
sometimes but it's not that
I just want to understand
how people tick I want to understand
every facet of everything that I can
possibly understand that just that
intrigues me
um so it's not so much of a I don't know
everything but I want to agree in a
conversation that I might not know about
that way we can continue the
conversation I can learn so now today
for me you know
I've got my bad moments just like
everybody else
um you know there's days that I wake up
and I'm like uh I don't want to get up
today but for the most part you know
it's hard to not stay positive with the
way things are for me now
um I could
have a completely different circumstance
as far as patient outcome than I did and
of course dating is difficult I mean I
think it's difficult for everybody
because a lot of dating has really
boiled down to do I like this picture or
not left or right
um that's you know obviously difficult
with a person with a lot of scars
and you know really all it took was just
one person that I was interested in that
was interested in me
being willing to
let me show them how much I would care
for them you have a beautiful girlfriend
out there thank you thank you she is she
is
um she always she always makes jokes
like that guy was a little walked out
she was like that guy was like looking
at you I don't know why I was like
she's probably wondering how in the heck
I landed such a beautiful girlfriend
she has a burn on her arm right yes yes
yes different accident
um but
yes so uh we talked about that but I had
a friend
um
uh Sandy Nair Moore who runs a
non-profit magic moments in Birmingham
which is kind of it's basically make a
wish or similar to make a wish but for
Birmingham area residents and she knew
her and was like hey I think you guys
would would be great you know to meet
and talk about what you guys go through
so
we met uh for dinner in 2017 or 18.
I felt like it was a date
um she kind of was just like hey we're
just meeting and uh and then of course
she ended up moving to Huntsville for a
couple years and then she moved back in
January 2023 so
she sent me an Instagram DM I was like
hey I'm moving back we should get dinner
and uh we went and had dinner and the
rest is history now she's out in Santa
Monica with me so
what do you uh what would you say is the
most important thing you've learned from
all this Christian
man there's so many things
um
probably the most important thing
probably the most important thing is
empathy
um and I know we've I've kind of
expanded on that a little bit but
you know a lot of times
you know life now is for a lot of folks
very go go go we're getting social media
here other media here we got all this
stuff in our face
um so you know we're driving down the
road and there's someone in front of us
that's going slow right
and
speed up I'm in a hurry go go go
I fall into those moments I won't lie
um but
I think the most important thing is to
have empathy for other people
um what I try to do now is if I get
behind a slow car I'm like all right
this is they just baked a fresh apple
pie they got in the front seat and they
want to be careful so they're just
driving slow so they don't ruin the pie
let's try what I try to I really just
trying to per approach other people from
a very open
minded perspective
um and of course and I think sometimes
the key is understanding exactly that
you may not know exactly why they're
doing what they're doing but there's a
there's probably a very good reason for
it exactly exactly and like we see a lot
of times on your Channel
it's you know we we never truly know
what someone's going through I mean a
lot of people can put on a a smile and a
pretty face
um and you know you've really never know
what happened to that person this
morning or last night or I mean
so just just trying to be a little bit
more empathetic I think
of course you know coming from Alabama
we get
um I Won't Say I'm apolitical
um I've I've majored in political
science in college used to love politics
but
I'm way too empathetic to be a
politician now because I want to help
everybody I want to be friends with
everybody and
um I want everybody to like me and of
course being a politician that's not
really the way that works
um and of course being in Alabama we get
a little bit more of one side than the
other which
is what it is and of course I tried to
approach that with an open mind as well
but um yeah I think really empathy is is
probably the most important thing
um you know just trying to instead of
jumping straight to a
well I I want to get you on that or I
want to catch you on that it's more of a
all right well why don't we just have a
civilized conversation see you got
differences I got differences let's see
if we can find some commonalities and
kind of meet in the middle so excellent
all right Christian thank you so much
for sharing your story
I'm glad you're doing well thank you